A few years prior to Apple's launch of the iPhone,...
...Son was visiting Steve Jobs in California...
...and offered him sketches of a prototype device...
...that combines functionalities of the iPod and a mobile phone.
Knowing Apple was developing the iPhone, Jobs refused,...
...so Masa got him to agree to exclusive rights for their product in Japan,...
...bringing Softbank and Masa a lot of success.
This wasn't his first big business deal however.
While attending the University of California at Berkeley,...
...he invented a digital translator and sold it to Sharp...
...for 100 million yen or about a million dollars.
Using that money, he founded Softbank, which is a household name in Japan...
...and airs popular commercials with Tommy Lee Jones and a dog.
For a brief period during the dot-com bubble, Masa was the world's richest man...
...before 99 percent of his deals failed.
At the center of his reputation is one very important transaction.
In 2000, he made a 20-million-dollar investment...
...in an unknown Chinese startup called Alibaba...
...and a young founder named Jack Ma.
"I could tell from the way he talks, the way he looks,..."
"...he has charisma, he has leadership."
Softbank's stake in Alibaba is now worth 138 billion dollars,...
...one of the most lucrative venture investments of all time.